hey everybody it's Mike freighter here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrolia.l 2-3.5.5
prevent the ReUse of identifiers for a
defined period of time
[Music]
if you're a defense contractor is
feeling overwhelmed tired and alone try
and understand all of this cmmc dfars
and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff on
top of an already colossal workload well
I've got great news for you you found
your home here at on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance Hero Let's jump let's throw
on the cape and let's jump into it
cmfccontrolia.l 2-3.5.5 prevent the
ReUse of identifiers for a defined
period of time well here's the first
question what the heck is an identifier
anyone I mean seriously again could we
just talk in plain English here for a
minute this stuff is Tough Enough all
right I don't get it
actually it turns out that what we've
got is some pretty smart people on staff
here and we do actually get it turns out
somebody fed me the right script this
time all right an identifier is
something that identifies an account or
person as unique so a great example
would be an active directory username
okay that is an identifier maybe they
have a unique system ID that's an
identifier
why don't you want to reuse an
identifier because let's say Bob Smith's
our CEO and access to everything uh is
his right he's got access to everything
he leaves and a year later Barbara Smith
comes to work assumes the same
identifier as B Smith and magically
Barbara's got access to all kinds of fun
stuff she should not have had all very
preventable by just not reusing the
identifiers so to dig in more let's look
at precisely what the assessors are
looking for on this one
two points of assessment here determine
if a period within which identifiers
cannot be reused is identified or excuse
me defined uh so number one we can just
sort of throw in a random answer here so
we'll say a period of 10 days or one
week is defined within the it operations
policy so again the idea is set whatever
the amount of time is where that
identity uh you know won't be reused
maybe it is it will never be reused uh
and again I think that's really what the
control is calling for determine if
reusive identifiers is prevented within
the defined period identifiers cannot be
reused within the defined period because
the identifier is disabled but still
exists leaving it unable to be reused so
again if you're never deleting the user
out of active directory you're just
going to disable the account boom it's
really impossible for it to be reused
unless someone wants to reactivate it
which again you would just have to have
a policy they don't do that now at on
call we work with defense contractors
just like you who have had this D fars
nist itar and cmmc compliance stuff
dropped in their laps like a single on a
sunny day we teach you how to level up
and be a proper on-call compliance hero
for your company eliminating gaps gray
areas and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
as your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content we're putting out there
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better smash
the Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance starts roll it out a 10x
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
[Music]
thank you foreign